one of the things I love about this film
which is about voyeurism
surveillance watching is the way that
you use everyday technology in the
detective story cell phones surveillance
video
smart watches
um and it's very natural to how we all
use
self smartphones and the way that we
leave little traces of ourselves
in the digital ether but I also love the
way you visualize the text messages in
so many different ways on screen you
give us a cell phone POV shot a couple
of times
um so I just wanted to know how you sort
of thought about visualizing the
technology that is so integral to our
lives but you know how do you put that
on screen how do you make it cinematic
questions
[Music]
device the modern technology so actually
smartphone and all these devices was the
last thing I wanted to deal with
there's a tone treatment
[Music]
messages
so when I came up with the first
treatment and having seen looking at
this whole
bunch of text messages I was like oh no
this is going to be a problem
[Music]
so I was imagining because this is
should be a classical elegant romantic
romance movie I was imagining um riding
with the fountain pen in a very
beautiful elegant handwriting on a
beautiful piece of paper but this is
something like a teenager's exchanging a
whole bunch of texts
so I even thought maybe I should change
the period to 40s or 50s of Hollywood
so-called conventional Noir period
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
however as as important as it is to sort
of convey this classical Elegance to the
movie I thought it was also important to
portray this realism of this
contemporary period so I thought this is
very important element for the film
again
so this is something so how I go about
it when I'm going about filmmaking and I
actually changed my strategy and instead
of avoiding it I actually actively
decided to tackle it as if I had
originally intended to do so from the
very beginning
[Music]
and that's why I used smartphone using
the smart watch I'm sorry Smart Watch
instead of note taking for the detective
and ultimately the most important thing
was using the translation app because
100 devices
and I also sort of saw this as an
extension of our body parts when using
these devices
so it's actually in in a way it becomes
our eyes and our ears and for when
they're using the translation app it
becomes their ears
[Music]
these devices and recording them they're
actually talking and confessing was
their actual inner thoughts into these
devices
so it's a little jar or plate that they
have secret um poor their secrets into
it they have poured their soul and they
have poured all the emotions into this
little jar this is
so it's no longer this cold-hearted
device but it has become this
something
though
foreign
so that's why it came about I was
possible to use this uh
from POV for the film
um
so I thought when they're texting each
other it's not that they're looking at
the device they're looking at the other
people
the lover herself
so on the other hand I thought it works
as a film device to have her POV as well
I'm curious
um you know tongwei is such an
incredible Femme Fatale in this film
did you write this with her in mind or
did you just always when you were
writing think you were going to have a
Chinese woman who was living in Korea or
was this specifically for her
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
sitting down to write a script I sat
down with the co-writer whom I work with
all the time and we talked about what
should we write about what's the story
foreign
[Music]
and the only thing I told her as
elements for the story was about the
male character that he needs to be a
detective he needs to be kind and he
needs to be clean
foreign
foreign so he meets this lady and falls
in love
because
and that was the only thing I had the so
that's good
so I asked my co-writer so what kind of
lady should it be
and she told me she needs to be Chinese
out of the blue
and she said
then we can cast time away
[Music]
and that is just to say how much we love
Tang Wei from Ann Lee's lost caution
foreign
uh
you don't you don't know
[Music]
so that was why the reason why we went
to set the characters are Chinese and
that was actually the beginning uh the
starting point of the movie however when
we went about actually writing and
digging the story We of course went
about it in a way that for the audience
when they were looking at the film they
only see that yes they understand now
there's no denying that the character
needs to be Chinese
well director Park thank you so much for
talking about this film with us thank
you all for being here today
thank you very much
decision to leave is in theaters and it
really welcomes a many repeat viewings I
will just say so go see it again